arriba de esta línea tengo cierta
cantidad de cajas y podemos observar que
en cada una de estas barras amarillas
tenemos 10 cajas aunque hay tenemos 12
4 5 6 7 8 9 y 10 y además tengo dos de
estos grupos de diez cajas entonces
tengo dos decenas y por acá tenemos tres
unidades hay tres unidades
y debajo de esta línea tengo cuatro
grupos de diez cajas cuatro decenas
y 1 2 3 4 5 unidades
5 unidades así es que en el primer
número tengo dos decenas y tres unidades
o sea veintitrés dos decenas y tres
unidades y en el segundo número tengo
cuatro decenas y cinco unidades cuatro
decenas cinco unidades o sea 45 y ahora
lo que quiero hacer es sumar estos
números a que hay 23 más 45 vamos a
sumar lo que vamos a sumar todas estas
cajas
vamos a sumar esta cantidad más de esta
cantidad y vamos a sumar 23 45 y bueno
de este lado tenemos 3 unidades y 5
unidades y si las sumamos pues nos van a
quedar 8 unidades nunca y vamos a
dibujarlos por aquí 1 2
estas 3 y luego 1 2
45 estas otras 5 y nos quedan 8 unidades
y si nos vamos de este lado donde
escribimos estas cantidades con dígitos
o numerales pues tenemos 3 + 5 y 3 + 5
es 8 18 unidades y 8 unidades porque ya
ahora vamos a regresar por aquí vamos a
sumar estas dos decenas más cuatro
decenas déjame copio y pego esto de aquí
ok y lo vamos a pasar por acá que
llevamos dos decenas éstas dos decenas
de aquí pero dos más cuatro son seis
llevamos dos
entonces tenemos uno dos tres cuatro
cinco seis decenas seis decenas porque
dos decenas más cuatro decenas son seis
decenas y como puedes observar es súper
sencillo aunque aquí sumando 23 más 45
lo que hice fue irme a las unidades y
sumar las tres más 5 es 83 más 5 es 8 y
después simplemente sume las decenas dos
decenas más cuatro decenas son seis
decenas que hay dos decenas más cuatro
decenas son seis decenas y entonces esta
suma es 68 16 68